if you're at all interested in pushing a
performance productivity or creativity
then it's hard not to get excited by the
concept of flow States flow states of
states of optimal human performance this
is your performance when you're a
hundred percent focused on a single task
it's you with zero distractions when all
your mental and physical resources are
called upon so what's really happening
here
well I've addressed the psychology of
flow States before to briefly recap the
generally agreed explanation is that
when a specific activity seems important
and challenging enough we allow our
prefrontal cortex to switch off state is
technically known as transient
hypofrontality our mind stops wandering
distractions fall away and instead we
become creatures of pure instinct
there's only the present moment and the
challenge in front of us I liken this to
driving and talking when we drive and
talk on the phone at the same time we
may think that we're still able to
respond quickly but in fact with four
times more likely to have an accident
because our attention is divided the
internal monologue can do the exact same
thing to you when you're playing a
computer game or sparring with an
opponent distracting your attention away
from the present moment this unique
pattern of activity in the brain also
triggers the release of specific
neurotransmitters dopamine serotonin
norepinephrine and an and amide newer
chemically this is very similar to a
fight-or-flight response except with
Karma and more in control our brainwaves
also slow down and enter a theta state
and whether we're writing an essay
wrapping engaged in conversation
snowboarding or fighting our performance
improves at least this is the popular
narrative it's a nice little bedtime
story but there are issues with this
idea and that's what I want to break
down in this two-part video series here
in part one I'll be discussing the true
nature of a flow state and in part two
I'll be talking about how to hack that
flow state in order to bring it on at
will so for starters I've often
questioned how a flow state can be
beneficial for writing an essay if it
causes your prefrontal cortex to shut
down this is the part of the brain we
use for planning problem-solving and
reasoning so if we lose these abilities
how can we possibly work better the
answer as it turns out is to do with the
precise part of the prefrontal cortex
that shuts down specifically it's an
area called the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex that shuts off while
the medial prefrontal cortex remains
active during creative tasks this makes
a lot of sense seeing as the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex is at
least partly responsible for our sense
of self whereas the medial prefrontal
cortex is all about the internal
generation of ideas so this way we can
maintain our creativity in our planning
whilst losing our self concern and our
little nagging voice of doubt this was
what was seen when looking at the brains
of rappers during improvisation so it
seems the prefrontal cortex in fact
shuts down selectively rather than
entirely and this is why we can still
plan and be creative while being
entirely focused on a single task but
I'm still not convinced that flow states
are just this one thing because when you
are focused deeply on writing an essay
or having a fascinating conversation you
don't tend to experience that cascade of
neurotransmitters when was the last time
you're writing an essay and your heart
rate went through the roof and you
started shaking if you want to learn how
to get into creative flow state then
check out my video on focus but if it's
ultra instincts or like high performance
you're more interested in then what can
you do so that's the other reason I
think that it's folly folly I say to
consider a flow state purely in terms of
hypofrontality because there's another
way you can shut down your prefrontal
cortex through stress any
fight-or-flight response will cause you
to produce cortisol norepinephrine and
dopamine when was the last time you're
nervous in an interview or scared for
your life and you want a hundred percent
focused stress hormones shut down your
prefrontal cortex in just the same way
and cortisol is particularly damaging to
your hippocampus and your ability to
store memories this is why you might
stutter when you're speaking publicly
and it's why you get the yips in golf
this is sometimes referred to as giving
yourself a self-love bottome so it's
funny how the prefrontal cortex is at
the root of all evil when someone's
selling a book on flow states and it's
the most important part of your brain
when someone is selling a stress
management technique simplicity sells
but are we to say that every time you're
stressed you're in a flow State no I
didn't think so
speaking anecdotally you often hear
people advise that you relax into flow
in other words they suggest that you
enter a flow state by first being highly
stressed and then finding a state of
calm within that stress the eye of the
storm cortisol may completely impair
your higher functioning brain regions
including the likes of the medial
frontal cortex it may negatively impact
on working memory which as I've
discussed on this channel before appears
to be at the heart of our visuospatial
scratchpad and highly useful for
planning and taking action from
experience the prefrontal cortex
definitely can be useful during highly
focused activity so perhaps a flow state
is really about being highly engaged
with the activity stimulating the
release of excitatory neurotransmitters
and hormones but the same time remaining
calm enough in order to use those higher
functioning brain regions as needed this
may also explain at least partly why
flow states are also associated with the
slower theta brain waves and it could
all also be linked to something called
heart rate variability heart rate
variability refers to changes in our
heart rate during inhalation and
exhalation far from being steady your
heart rate fluctuates all the time and
this happens at least partly in response
to your breath via the vagus nerve when
you breathe in this causes a minor
activation of the sympathetic nervous
system thereby increasing your heart
rate and when you breathe out you
trigger the parasympathetic nervous
system and thereby enter a more relaxed
state if your heart rate doesn't vary in
this way then it may suggest that you
are sympathetic dominant meaning that
you're overstressed and possibly
overtrained you need more time to
recover what's more is that this heart
rate variability also seems to predict
optimal performance in elite individuals
such as Navy SEALs and Special Forces
operatives in fact consistent top
performers seem to have a different
physiological stress response than
average performers it's been observed
that Olympic caliber athletes and
special operatives personnel demonstrate
both stronger sympathetic responses to
challenge and greater parasympathetic
expression during rest in other words
they're capable of being more on during
competition and more off when they need
to recover once again things aren't
quite as clear cut as they at first seem
while good heart rate variability is
generally considered to be a good thing
and positive for health and recovery it
actually seems that the top performers
exhibit lower heart rate variability
during extreme stresses or what is known
as a metronomic heart rate this suggests
a much stronger sympathetic nervous
system response and somehow top
performers maintain this whilst also
managing to remain clear-headed and
focused a doctor from Yale Medical
School named Andy Morgan conducted
fascinating research on the brains of
men trained for mental
see under extreme stress he found that
they produce greater amounts of
neuropeptide Y or n py and DHEA DHEA is
interesting because it manages to buffer
the effects of cortisol on the
hippocampus perhaps allowing athletes
and Special Forces operatives to
maintain their spacial awareness for
heightening performance during stress
DHEA is also a neuro steroid that
increases the excitability of neurons
potentially helping to speed up synaptic
transmissions and helping our brain to
run faster npy is meanwhile linked with
blood pressure appetite learning and
memory and helps us to reduce the
effects of norepinephrine thereby
maintaining the usefulness of certain
prefrontal brain regions during stress
imagine turning on the gas in your brain
releasing performance enhancing neuro
chemicals and losing all distraction
while at the same time being able to
maintain perfectly a headedness and
possibly even enhanced reaction times a
related term is heart rate coherence
this plots the pattern of variability as
either being erratic and all over the
place or calm and steady in other words
it measures how often the dip and peak
in heart rate occur rather than how
extreme those differences are in a
coherent state the breathing becomes
rhythmic as do the heart rate variations
the heart rhythm patterns also become
predictable what's interesting is that
coherence also correlates with an
increase in DHEA and massive decrease in
cortisol so again this might demonstrate
that by breathing in a rhythmic and calm
manner were able to maintain calm focus
even when we're physiologically aroused
there was actually a study that looked
for a correlation between heart rate
currents and other measures of flow
States the results were mixed but there
were some correlations suggesting either
that there's a connection here but
there's a little bit more going on than
just coherence or that there are
methodological problems with the study
which I would speculate is probably at
least part of the reason for those
findings but there's definitely
something of interest here that's worth
exploring and I'll be looking at that
more in the next video so this is
certainly all speculation and I maintain
that flow probably comes in a number of
different forms there's no one perfect
vision
core response to every situation even
though it'd be nice to think otherwise
but it seems that being able to stay
calm during heightened sympathetic
response is one of the keys to
performing optimally want to increase
arousal and motivation and vigilance
drink performance and dull tasks but our
aim is to control that response during
competition or intense stress we must be
a hundred percent focused to react to
reflexively and instinctively whilst
also been calm enough to prevent our
brain function from shutting down it's
the difference between being psyched out
and psyched up and in part two of this
video I'll be looking at how we can tap
into a flow state quickly and
effectively using a number of flow hacks
based on all of this theory actually
decent ones that might work including
nootropics tacks for inducing flow so
there you go I just want to shed a
little bit of light on two flow States
and how there may be a little bit more
complicated and nuanced than a lot of
people seem to think hope you found this
video useful interesting guys if you did
then please like it please share it
around it helps them greatly let me know
in the comments down below what you
think of flow state really is if you
want more information on this and links
to all the studies that I referenced and
check out the link in the description
down below and that take you to the
accompanying blog post which goes with
this video down there you'll also find
links to my social media including
Instagram and Twitter and Facebook and
on there you can follow me see what I'm
doing in the gym find out about new
posts and videos etc likewise stay tuned
and subscribe to this channel if you'd
like more videos on brain training
performance bodybuilding Fitness
technology productivity if that all
sounds good then thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now